Дарина із сином вже прикрашають новорічну ялинку.
Чіпляють іграшки, запалюють вогники і кладуть подарунки.
Адже цьогоріч її сім’я відзначатиме Різдво швидше, ніж зазвичай – 25 грудня.
В усі попередні роки ми святкували 7 січня.
Але цього року нам хочеться все-таки бути частиною одного цілого разом з усім світом, разом з Європою,
разом з тими друзями, які нас підтримують зараз у війні з Росією.
Тому що не хочеться асоціювати себе з Росією ніяк.
Ні у свята бути разом, у будь-які свята, які ми зазвичай відзначали за юліанським календарем.
Тому Святий Миколай цього року приходив до маленького Дані за григоріанським календарем – 6 грудня.
Приніс мандаринки, цукерки та іграшки.
Чогось наша славна Україна зажурилася.
А ми тую червону калину підіймемо.
А ми нашу славну Україну, гей-гей, розвеселимо.
А Дарина вже обдумує святкове меню. Хоч цьогоріч будуть святкувати скромніше - через війну.
Цього року будемо намагатися мати на столі 12 страв.
Традиційно це кутя.
Буде світла, не буде світла – все одно будемо готувати заздалегідь,
щоб якось була атмосфера справжнього свята.
Якщо не буде світла, будемо намагатися ставити на стіл консервацію
або наші якісь традиційні страви з наших традиційних овочів: буряк, капусту замаринуємо…
Цього року Православна церква України дозволила святкувати Різдво і 25 грудня, і 7 січня - за рішенням парафій.
На це рішення вплинули настрої у суспільстві - насамперед з огляду на повномасштабну війну.
Тобто напередодні самого свята парафія повинна голосуванням чи усним,
чи зборами своїми визначитися, в яку саме дату їм святкувати.
Наскільки мені відомо, є вже такі оголошені випадки,
зокрема в Катерининському соборі міста Чернігова буде дві різдвяні служби для тих і для тих.
Потім ці цифри проаналізують, щоб зрозуміти, чи переходити в майбутньому
зі святкуванням релігійних свят з юліанського на григоріанський календар.
У міру того, як астрономія ставала все більш точною наукою,
виникали питання до класичного юліанського календаря,
тому що він трошечки не дотягує чверть доби до того, щоб покривати весь астрономічний рік.
Тому в 16 столітті в західній Європі, власне, в Римській імперії колишній західній і в католицькій церкві
було прийнято змінити трошки календар церковний, щоб він відповідав астрономічному з більшою чіткістю.
Тоді, наприкінці 16-го століття, усі католицькі держави перейшли на григоріанський або новоюліанський календар, а православні - ні.
Хоча нині лише третина православних церков живе за старим стилем.
Коли прийшли "совєти" до влади, то вони перейшли в світському календарі на григоріанський, на західний.
А церква залишилася на юліанському календарі.
І таким чином виходить, що наші православні, так само як і наші греко-католики, святкують за давньою традицією,
за юліанським календарем, хоча в світському календарі це припадає вже на 7 число.
Українська греко-католицька церква цьогоріч відзначатиме Різдво 7 січня,
хоча деякі парафії за кордоном вже давно перейшли на святкування 25 грудня.
У церкві вважають, що дискусію слід вести про зміщення дати не лише Різдва,
а повністю переходити на новий календар.
Та робити це потрібно усім разом.
Ми хочемо робити таку календарну реформу і переходити на новий календар в Україні разом з іншими церквами,
щоб таке рішення якоїсь із церков, в даному випадку ми говоримо про нашу церкву (УГКЦ), яка озвучує таку засаду,
не створило додаткових поділів, але навпаки -
щоб календарна реформа посприяла єдності українського суспільства.
Тобто разом з іншими церквами звершувати такі календарні реформи.
Щоправда, в УГКЦ вважають, що робити це потрібно вже після перемоги.
Війна не є сприятливим часом для проведення календарних реформ,
тому що реформа - це завжди така річ, яка послаблює спільноту, послаблює церковну структуру.
І війна - це час, коли ми маємо усі наші зусилля скерувати на захист нашої Батьківщини.
Думки вірян щодо цього різні.
За опитуванням соціологічної групи "Рейтинг" за останній рік кількість тих, хто святкує Різдво 25 грудня,
зросла з 4 до 11 відсотків.
Кожен четвертий відзначатиме його в обидві дати.
На 16% зменшилася кількість тих, хто святкуватиме Різдво 7 січня - тепер це лише трохи більше половини українців.
Майже удвічі побільшало тих, хто підтримує ідею перенесення святкування Різдва на 25 грудня –
з 26 відсотків торік до 44-ох цього року.
Переважно це мешканці західної і центральної України та Києва.
Ще не обирали, але вже, мабуть, з минулого року, то два рази зустрічаємо.
25-го з усім світом і вже 6-го ввечері за батьківськими традиціями.
Ми не переходили на григоріанський календар, воно все по-старому як було, так і залишилося.
Різдво одне Христове, один Христос, то як можна святкувати два народження?
Повпливало те, що Україна, українці не хочуть бути з російською православною церквою, яка святкує Різдво 7 січня.
25 грудня святкує Захід.
Україна хоче в західну демократію, тому ми, наша сім’я будемо святкувати 25 грудня.
А от в УПЦ Московського патріархату - проти переносу Різдва на 25 грудня.
Представники ПЦУ коментують це так.
Ми зустрілися і зараз зустрічаємося з тим, що російська православна церква
вкидає всі свої можливості і сили в пропаганду сакралізувати календар.
Тобто вони говорять про те, що ні, нам цього не потрібно, ми будемо дотримуватися того, що було, і так далі.
А календар - це не є якась догматична система. Це просто відлік, по якому живемо ми.
За словами релігієзнавців, наприкінці цього століття різниця між календарями становитиме вже не 13, а 14 днів.
Тому все одно свята доведеться зміщувати на один день.
Або ж перейти на григоріанський календар, який є більш точним з астрономічної точки зору.
Перехід на інший церковний календар для людей означає зміну власне річного циклу.
Тобто це буде інший час посту, наприклад, тобто піст буде починатися раніше.
Це буде інше святкування Нового року.
Точніше нарешті святкування Нового року буде прив’язане до святкування Різдва так, як воно було традиційно.
Цей процес є довгим і складним, адже віряни в Україні звикли жити за традиціями.
Тому українські церкви проти різкого переходу на новий стиль. А для вірян головне:
Я думаю, що цього року показник свята - це перш за все, що будуть рідні поруч, будуть близькі.
Тому зберемо мам, бабусь, дідусів, всі будемо поруч.
Навіть якщо не буде світла - все одно будемо святкувати.
І найголовніше - будемо молитися за ЗСУ і щоб якнайшвидше закінчилася війна,
щоб більше захисників могли святкувати вдома зі своїми різними усі свята.
Вітаю всіх з Різдвом!